james cabrillon has done an outstanding
job since
uh joining the ball club making his ten
start he's four and two
and you know really what he has done
he's his major league debut against the
boston red sox at fenway park did an
outstanding job in five innings he's
winning four to one he gave up one run
in the first inning and that was after
loading the bases
first pitch of the game diving play alex
andrews he gets up the throne at first
and he got him
unbelievable sensational play by albus
andrews on the first pitch of the game
this is what we're talking about for
fourth of july weekend fireworks at the
dish fireworks down the field elvis
about three feet deep out in left field
extendo to the backhand side
comes up and fires an absolute dime over
to mount olson
had a way to get it going early on sing
to me elvis
that's gold baby swinging
back there's the first strikeout for
caprara
nick pavetta in his 17th start of the
season looking to bounce back after
tuesday's outing against the royals
four in the third and six runs goes to
the curve to strike out kemp
boy nasty wow
what a breaking ball right there looked
like a curveball he got on top and just
snapped it off
look at the break on that ball line
shot left center field to base it
santana is over there
he's going to throw the third oh she's
going to try for third he's going to
make it
chapman to second and he's in there
that's a mistake by danny santana
making pavetta work here in the first
3-2 again
and it's hung on two behind the plate
and a big punch out for nick pavetta in
the first
two and two da vasquez gonzalez to
follow and then santana
swing enemies
second strikeout for caprarian
strike three called on the outside
[Applause]
corner
oh he snaps off of beauty that thing is
devastating
and it's strikeout number four
and that's four strikeouts a two-out
base runner for the red sox
and alex ferdugo and he stings one into
right center field
hernandez takes off for third as
laureato gets to it and they'll stop
tk at third and for dugo ties in safely
excellent base runner right there
up the middle kemp is there kept flips
to first in time
so to pray and gets out of it a couple
of runners stranded in scoring position
six times or so in the forehead after
the game he was talking through
the bunt decision and he strikes out
here
against another pavetta curveball he
wasn't too pleased with himself for the
way that bunt
unfolded late last night well he may be
slapping himself again right after that
yeah
swinging the miss struck him out and
what i'm getting out here
is instead of going to that off speed
maybe a little earlier in the count
where guys have started to take
advantage he doubles up
a couple fastballs in a row you start to
flip the script on him a little early
broken back shallow right center brown
coming in brown grabs it
santana is retired and so are the red
sox in the top of the fourth
still a lot of stuff that's still boxed
up i don't know what the hell to do with
it
that is on the outside corner
back door for pavetta
[Applause]
victorious today they can maintain their
deficit for the astros but
starting tuesday it's all about one game
equals
that's 92 miles an hour and that is
seven
strikeouts for capralia 17th start of
the season working in tandem with
christian vasquez
the 2-2 inside and loreano went around
strikeout number seven for pavetto
fastball up and in he tried to check
that swing but couldn't with all the
momentum going forward
that's a swing right there that is a
swing
that 12 to six is coming straight from
the top and dropping straight down
that is going straight into a strikeout
number eight for pavetta
three in a row he always brings such an
intensity
to his starts and he's cruising right
now he gets chad pinder to ground to
debra's
inning over once again and that's 13 in
a row set down by pavetta
two hits for the sox just one knock for
the a's
and verdugo goes the opposite way
chasing pender back
to the wall and it's off the wall
verdugo coasts into second he's got his
second double to begin the sixth
first pitch swinging into left field
pinder comes up with it they stop
berdugo
and the sox have him at the corners he
jumped all over that pitch
so debra's in the cleanup spot and a.l
all-star
swings at the 0-1 camp comes up with it
and turns two but the sox have the
game's first run verdugo in through the
back door
and 18 curve balls from him 2-2
oh that is a beauty nice
nine punch-outs for pavetta
he just snapped this pitch off
unbelievable depth on that curveball
as a hitter you're not expecting that
two strikes just to snap it off like
that
no chance well he'd thrown one before to
try to get a chase and he
lands that one and ties his season high
in case he's at
22 pitches and counting here in the six
payoff again
and he strikes out olson and nick
pavetta with a season high
10 strikeouts two balls and two strikes
the pitch swing and a miss got him away
a fastball at 92
and for caprilian that's eight k's
strike three call number nine for
caprarian man these two guys
are dealing donnick swinging
caprian wins the battle career high 10
strikeouts for the young right-hander
as he walks off the mound a terrific
performance this afternoon for james
caprilian
doug is psyched why not his kid was good
today
so in a one-nothing game lorianno's in
scoring position
it was a strike to brown
this is a pop-up behind the second base
bag
hernandez comes in and he puts it away
seven shutout from nick pavetta
sox trying to take this series against
the athletics
and he goes and the pitch is low
no throwing the red sacks want to make
sure that bolt doesn't get up and go to
third so a stolen base
all right so two outs barnes trying to
slam it shut
and the bottom of the ninth inning is o2
he
strikes out brown sucks win
x him